which brings me to our next story
yeah now i know you already had some
thoughts on this daniel because this one
gets spicy but uh i wanted to say this
real quick before we get into it the
reason one of the reasons i wanted to
lead with that story about the the
assassination attempt is because you
know i'm worried about the violence
escalating and the rhetoric escalating
and that was a real world example of a
potential escalation of political
rhetoric because check out this story
the guardian reports congressman echoes
trump's claim that clinton aides
deserved to die
jim jordan's statement on fox news is
another example of violent rhetoric
entering the republican mainstream
analysts say okay
let me give you the quick version before
we get into all the nitty-gritty
the durham investigation has made some
very serious accusations against the
clinton campaign that they were
simply put spying on donald trump as a
candidate and as the president very very
serious criminal allegations
donald trump stated in a stronger time
people would be put to death for this
jim jordan said donald trump's
statements were right on target
now the media is reporting that trump
has called for the death of these people
and that a member of congress has agreed
they should die
and that is a dramatic escalation of
rhetoric
and to be fair i mean even trump's
statement was a little bold and probably
not what we need to hear right now but
of course the media is not going to sit
back and say trump said people got the
death penalty in the past for doing
things like this he didn't say they
should get it but of course that's
that's the narrative they're going to
play towards
and now we're marching towards one side
is going to see this they're going to
say donald trump wants to kill these
people they're going to be saying this
see if the fascists get elected they're
going to start killing people you see
what trump said oh you see what the
guardians reporting the clinton aides
deserve to die and then you've got
people on the right who are like the
media's lying about it and the clintons
were committing very serious crimes
seditious crimes and they need to be
held accountable now you have the
democrat establishment base saying trump
you know trump's people are trying to
imprison his rivals meanwhile the
january state committee is doing the
exact same thing
here we go yeah there's one of the
problems that the previous president had
frequently and it was his own making
um is the imprecision of language
creates
problems that take the focus away from
where the attention should be so there's
this problem right now with with the
durham investigation and it's serious
but his imprecision of language would
just that that's not what we're
attacking so now everyone's talking
about this and and the problem with that
is that you want people to focus on the
durham report but you've lured them away
because you did not choose your words
properly by the way this headline also
is grammatically incorrect my mom taught
me such good english i have to point
that out because that's good english
such good english
well she didn't teach me such good
english she taught me english well yes
right yeah deserved his past tense
deserve those
that makes it sound like they have
already died
and they deserved it yeah it should be
the clinton aides deserve like they are
worthy they are deserving
they are deserving of death yeah so it
just bothers me that that's how they
phrased it but it's a little bit more
titillating it's a little bit sexier and
i think it's intentional maybe maybe
it's intentional in that they want
people to believe they did die yeah only
jeffrey epstein died
i thought his word position would get
better when he got banned off of twitter
i was like okay now he doesn't have a
character limit he can take some time
and write out an official statement on
his email his website but no this is
like trump
he's notorious for having read the art
of war i believe it was a big part of
his move uh growing up in his business
but this is an example of when your
enemy is making a mistake you don't
interrupt them yeah they were about to
go after hillary and trump opened his
big mouth
this was the first headline i saw about
it literally this was the first headline
i saw about it yesterday on twitter
and
if i had not
taken the due diligence to dig deeper
that would have been everything that i
saw and it's just insane we haven't even
walked through
the allegations against hillary yet
because this story has taken uh the
front page
and because the the escalation is
you know look
it is so difficult to explain to people
the inner workings of all of these
stories because they're so complicated
when i when i'm talking to people and i
say do you know who who durham is the
durham investigation they're familiar
they're like no what's that all right
let's start from page one and you gotta
walk them all the way through it but
when you get a headline that's like
donald trump says they should die
that's all they see yeah and they don't
know anything about why trump said it
they can't understand
and so i see these memes all the time
from the democrat base these lefties on
twitter and everything
genuinely confused by what's going on
because they don't know what's happening
because cnn won't tell them and that's
all they're willing to listen to and
watch because they're irresponsible
individuals so thus they end up seeing
these stories and they're like what's
the who's durham what is they even about
why is trump saying that trump's bad oh
man yeah
trump thinks these people deserve to be
killed and and they don't know any of
the background story and again that's
the problem you make the story about
yourself also which is a huge issue
let your enemies kill themselves uh if
that's what they're doing but don't
interrupt their mistake but he he does
and and that's unfortunate let's read a
little bit of this story because we'll
get into the details here they say
anti-hate speech activists oh my have
condemned the republican u.s congressman
jim jordan for his apparent endorsement
of donald trump's declaration that
members of hillary clinton's campaign
staff should have been executed okay
jordan has started on fox and friends
that the former president was right on
target when he accused clinton's aides
of spying on him and that another time
in us history their crime would have
been punishable by death
uh trump didn't accuse them
durham did
trump just said wow that that's a crazy
accusation
it's crazy how the guardian is framing
it but the positions of the ohio right
winger and fierce trump loyalist who is
resisting efforts from a congressional
committee to explain his own role in the
deadly january 6 riot that trump inside
it look at that that trump trump's
inside look what they do
oh my god serves only to stoke further
the country's volatile you know what
is there um
is there a like this paragraph is
perfectly ironic yeah they say
serves only to stoke further the
country's volatile political divisions
which is literally what the sentence is
doing yeah it's amazing i love how they
say trump incited the violence when ray
epps he's this guy on the ground january
5th and 6th yelling at people to go into
the capitol telling him to do it and
adam kinzinger is like yeah but you know
he was just talking he didn't do
anything it's like yo if if it's not
incitement to directly tell people to do
it i don't know how you claim donald
trump was inciting anything be strong
we're gonna you know stand up for
ourselves all right bye and that was it
and then it's like oh no now people are
if trump did this it's his fault he also
tweeted to not attack the capitol police
on that day he was he was tweeting
against the violence so i really don't
understand this narrative
you know
as much as uh we see a lot of this
conflict escalating as much as i've said
you know early on in other segments when
trump has the durham investigation going
for the clintons when the clintons are
waging you know political warfare
against him and you've got two factions
using the weight of government and law
enforcement and the judiciary to go
after each other it looks like civil
wars is on the horizon because
neither side will back down these are
powerful political elites that won't
back down
that's true
the facts don't matter the truth doesn't
matter
all that matters is that people have
feelings they act on right so you know
ben shapiro says facts don't care about
your feelings that's true in a certain
sense but feelings also don't care about
your facts if there are people who
believe the clintons and believe the
machine and the democrats they're going
to act upon that and that will lead to
very serious conflict that being said
it's very obvious what they're doing and
how they're lying those of us that have
been paying attention whether you're
conservative or liberal or whatever
we're watching the news we know for a
fact the people who are in alignment
with hillary clinton and podesta and
these other high-profile democratic
individuals are lying relentlessly cnn
garbage like joe rogan took horse
dewormer and people believe it people
believe this trump incited the riot or
the insurrection and oh well i got
whoa whoa the guardian did say riot
i'll give him that one i guess yeah
yeah well the guardian is a rag i mean
it has been for quite some some time i
mean it it's just pure propaganda like a
lot of the media what was funny about
the cnn stuff and the horse de warmer
and all that is that then as time goes
on not only to find out they're a bunch
of liars but they're also a bunch of
pedophiles um and they're all a bunch of
sexual degenerates right i mean like
it's it's it's within within one week
just just make for people who know the
context aren't interrupted but in one
week we had two different high-ranking
producers implicated i believe they were
both arrested and charged weren't they
yeah yeah
yeah and so these are the people who are
are are sharing the the the truth with
the american people so
you know it's it's frustrating that
these if there's an escalation of
tension or or growing tension
the media has a role that they're
playing with it and they of course are
are stoking these fires because they
have a business and their business is to
get clicks and to get people to buy
their publication i mean that's nothing
new to the media we've been dealing with
this for 200 years um but but that's
what their role is in this in this
incoming civil war and what the uh or
cold civil war that we're currently in
everyone describe it what we end up with
is the media these these corporate
interests accusing us of doing exactly
that
they're like oh they just they're
grifting and they just you know pander
the craziest thing is how
you know we have such disagreement in
the comments and the super chats on this
show and the nuance and the tim you're
wrong here's what really happened in us
reading and going oh wow we made a
mistake on that one and then you watch
cnn they have no interaction like that
cena just gets stuff wrong and they just
they don't care yeah sanjay gupta admits
to joe rogan on his own show yeah we
shouldn't have done this then goes back
on cnn and don lemon goes no we were
right and sanjay goes well you know you
were right that it's just it's just
unscrupulous they don't care it's
remarkable there are people who just
keep believing it falling for it and
they refuse to do any research to read
outside of what's happening in their
bubble
and they believe this insanity but i
tell you this
i don't it's not just these companies
want to make money that's a big
component of it it's political yeah
it it is their ideology i mean
the video that's been going viral for
the last day or so since this report
came out is the leslie stall on 60
minutes with donald trump where he talks
about these things and he says you know
they were spying on me they were
wiretapping me and
they were not and she says like this is
60 minutes we're a serious news
organization okay so maybe the facts
needed to come out and they needed four
years to come out but will 60 minutes
and leslie stall this sunday apologize
to donald trump or will they say you
know what
four years later the facts did come out
and and it looks like no they'll just
move on to another story and they'll
find some 16 year old kids with asthma
and they'll blame it on the big oil
industry and that will be the new 60
minute story and they will the way the
media gets out of this is they just
pretend it didn't happen
they just
administering minds there's this weird
power feeling of power when you censor
something that you don't agree with and
then you see that it affects it it works
and that you're basically you feel like
god it's like a sense of control that's
what these people experience i had to
fight that feeling as an as a moderator
i had to learn learn it and then tame it
and control it and notice it and these
people that's what they're getting
they're like yeah man i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna ignore trump i'm gonna do
like you said leslie sells not gonna
they're not gonna do the right thing and
and correct themselves no because
because they don't have to legally right
now they probably should and then
they're going to feel like god because
they're like wow we control the
narrative yeah mika brzezinski yeah
remember that yeah you know the
president thinks he can he can tell
people to think but that's our job no
it said something to that effect right
and then that day like snopes is like
she did not say that it was her job to i
love that that snopes fact check is it's
joe biden giving out crack pipes mostly
false mostly false he's also giving
syringes
that's what it was it's amazing but but
people see them mostly false and it
works for them that's all they need to
see they don't need to read it any
further and it's like
the funny thing about the whole crack
pipe story is if you look how they how
they gaslight
when you look up safe smoking kits this
is what they were funding 30 million
dollars towards drug programs which
included these kits if you look them up
they have meth pipes and crack pipes and
then all of a sudden biting goes uh jen
seki's like no we're not giving those
pipes and then all the fact checkers are
like no they're not giving pipes
but they just gas lighting everybody and
it works they fall for it every time
well it's the same as the well though
there's no problem on the border
ask secretary yeah ask secretary
mallorcas and he'll say no the border is
closed there is no problem on the border
next question and you say well look at
the video look at all that
ask the the people the ask the agents
and they'll say no next question there's
a mentor he's down at the border like
every other week and he's recording
video and going live and it's it's it's
real news it's it's it's completely real
and it's crazy how they're not reporting
on it i was just talking to lydia
downstairs before with before live i was
trying to brief myself on the durham
probe before i got here and i was trying
to watch a mixture of media i was
watching mostly fox because they're the
main people reporting on it because it's
basically a media blackout everywhere
else but i also watched maddow talking
about it today and in the headline like
in the little title card thing at the
bottom it said it was a trumpian theory
trumpian she literally it said trumpian
that's insane that's how biased they
reading the news you know uh
there's viral memes about the front page
of cnn
and it's like there's 18 stories about
trump and zero about biden and donald
trump has been president in over a year
and it's just yeah
why what and and no media gas lighting
is going to be greater than the gas
lighting we're just starting to
experience that will be the rest of this
year which will be the coveted gas
lighting because we get to november and
we get close to the election and mayors
and governors are going to say nine
months ago i took these mandates away
because my policies were saved and
they're going to say ian how dare you
accuse me of
of using this for political purpose it
has been months since my administration
and everyone's going to clap and say yes
you did take away those mandates you
fought to keep us safe i fought to keep
it and they're just gonna ignore the
fact that bars closed and restaurants
closed and mom lost her job and dad lost
the job the gaslighting well experience
for covid will be like no gaslighting
we've ever seen before but maybe some
people will wake up from it finally i
hope so like the super bowl i love it
they have a they have an indoor mask
mandate
in la and at this at the super bowl sofa
stadium they said before the super bowl
everybody would have to wear masks and
then there's this clip going around
where it's like the the
broadcasters are like oh look here we've
got leonardo dicaprio and ryan reynolds
and charlie's throne it's like just
showing all celebrities at a party and
none of them are wearing masks
so at a certain point if you've got how
many what was it like seventy thousand
people thousands and that stadium and
many of them were wearing masks but you
know you got so many not wearing it in
celebrities you still fall for these
narratives from the media you know maybe
you just can't be helped yeah but then
today in los angeles county some
nine-year-old kid sat in their english
class and took off the mask and they
were like suspended is that you know no
i'm sure it happened because because the
los angeles schools the masks are still
required tweeted this today it's such a
black pill moment for me to see all
these celebrities and all these elites
who are
hounding people calling people like
anti-science like grandma murderers for
not wearing a mask and they're all just
you know having fun the super bowl but
my
15 year old brother has to wear a mask
or he'll get kicked out of school like
it's just ridiculous thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you